my husband doesn't
know um what's going on um the other
gentleman does know that I am
married
um
and I don't want to leave my husband but
I don't want to break things off with
this other gentleman either so let me
let me put Let me give you another side
to this okay so okay number one I don't
think you love your husband I don't I
think you love the idea of the security
that seven plus years of of quasi stable
relationship brings I also think deep
down you understand that you are with
somebody of so little
character that he doesn't mind blowing
up another
family so he can hook up a
somebody so I think you found yourself
in like a
pretty pretty uh
dicey moral dilemma